tj9 podium was America's darling
everybody's favorite little Rudy
Huxtable from The Cosby Show but now she
is all grown up four months pregnant and
going through the biggest nightmare of
some life this is a story that everybody
is talking about about a week ago she
announced that she was pregnant and we
were so happy for Keyshia now she says
she was blindsided by her husband filing
for divorce and reportedly now he wants
her to prove the baby is his my Keisha
says she wants the world to know her
side of the story and that is why she's
only talking tauranga shel Turner let's
just go on the record did you cheat on
him during your mayor I haven't never
cheated on him during my marriage that's
not Hawaii you said you will have a
paternity test that's not an issue sure
there's no problem I've never been
unfaithful to my husband this is his
daughter you know it's one thing when
you choose to be in the spotlight it's
another thing the biggest thing and my
priority is she doesn't deserve her
Keyshia was emotional and raw when I
visited her this afternoon and heard
Lance at home the giant square cut
diamond ring she once wore proudly is
gone and get ready for this Keisha told
me she's not the one who cheated she
claimed her husband was so when early in
my marriage I was faced with this I was
ready to leave
I had divorce papers ready I presented
them to him he begged for another he
said please I want my family he said all
the right things and once I was pregnant
I did decide to give him that one last
chance so let's catch every one up on
the back story would you like to hold
him no he might go on after we fell in
love with her as Rudy Huxtable Keisha's
led a pretty quiet life doing charities
and her own podcast then after just four
months of dating Keisha and NFL star ed
Hartwell secretly got married
six months ago last week she announced
she was pregnant with a baby girl then
just two days ago
Edie filed for divorce one report claims
he wants a paternity test Keisha was
completely blindsided he left like it
was any other day
second goodbye I was still sleep in bed
and he text me you know saying hey can I
talk to you for a moment which was where
does it go give it you know okay
sure he was like you know this isn't
working but all I heard was I filed for
divorce this morning and I'm coming to
get my stuff you said that Edie had been
unfaithful to you
he confessed to it in his words in his
mouth period Wow there's no nursery
Keisha plans to sell the house before
her daughter is born as her head side of
the story while the former Real
Housewives of Atlanta husband has not
responded to our calls for comment do
you still love your husband I love who
he pretended to be hmm I have no desire
to continue to be married to him that's
why I'm doing this one interview and I'm
done I'm not going to continue to
revisit regurgitate but I'm also not
going to continue to allow people to
tell blatant lies about me I see your
heartbreaking
I'm grateful hmm despite all of this and
everything that happened I'm grateful
for my blessing and that's my little
girl
you
you